la voglia che ciò io di fare il letto la
mattina è qualcosa di assurdo ragazzi a
tutti i ragazzi e vero di avere un video
sono fa vj ed oggi siamo il nuovo blog
come ogni fottutissimo sabato apporti
che nessuno ancora contestato il fatto
che io metto in ordine le mie valigie
così però vabbè tanto mio ordine si era
già capito che non era al massimo ma che
annuncia le cuffie me ne sono accorta
adesso scusatemi che sono poi la gente
si suicida da parte di questa settimana
ragazzi è stata vinta da chiara che ha
fatto disegno epico dove o le cuffie e
rigorosamente perché io ormai senza
cuffie non esistono colori prima non è
la famiglia era un intruso del cazzo
niente quindi grazie chiara per la parte
che stupenda passiamo alle news della
settimana che sono e una come molti di
voi sapranno ormai la nostra vita è
giunta un termine ok siamo stiamo per
morire e vero dice zio favi perché ieri
l'altro questo blog esce sabato quindi
qualche giorno fa è uscito poche mondo
che in italiano si dice pokémon che
sarebbe l'applicazione per smartphone
che ti permette di giocare a poche mon
nella vita reale
siccome non è ancora uscita per iphone e
per android in versione italiano ma
quelli che hanno android ci hanno il
pene più lungo quindi se la possono
scaricare alcune persone hanno iniziato
a testare l'applicazione compreso me ho
soltanto fatto l'inizio cioè dove ti
devi solo registrare adesso il live nel
blog proverò ad uscire e vedere se
funziona perché ancora non l'ho provata
e andiamo a fare una prova sarà contenta
mia madre che mi dice sempre esci di
casa che giochi sempre videogiochi
adesso c'è un motivo per farlo let's go
ok ragazzi ci siamo allora ho avviato ad
es
sì però stai calmo ricordo durante il
gioco presta sempre attenzione
all'ambiente che ti circonda sì perché
adesso mi lancio in mezzo alla strada
mentre passati con gary dos sul
marciapiede va bene ma qua c'è l'erba
quando non c'è l'erba gusto gioco mente
c'è da drew qui chi cazzo è questo
questa è una palestra dove andare in
palestra [ __ ] non faccio neanche
fitness ma io come incontro i pokémon
devo andare in giro va bene usciamo ok
ragazzi sto camminando che cazzo c'è uno
zoom di merda ma veramente arrivo ci
arrivo ci arrivo i pipistrelli della
minkia sé ma devo andare in mezzo alla
strada a prenderlo del rivale rosso ma
veramente fani mente non è vero dice che
qualcuno ma dov'è ma va dentro mi dice
che c'è su bach qua dentro
ma che cazzo faccio scavalco non ho
ancora sbloccato scala roccia ma belgio
batte [ __ ] innescasse salto sulla
macchina il mio primo pokémon che volevo
catturare l'ho perso perché dopo scarica
muro amiche azzurri c'hanno magica per
caso e mi dice che qua c'è un seeking si
chiama così sto pokémon questa è una
palestra un luogo della mente che questo
avevo capito non hai molta esperienza
come allenatore vero tua madre ritorna
quando avrei qualcuno è la madonna
questi sono tutti a cerca i pokemon lega
think i vecchi conti giocando di
accedere alla palestra non riesco a
lungo ora quanta gente ci infila in
palestra e mi dice che ci sono dei
pokémon qua nell'erba alta quindi devo
entrare nel parco perché ovviamente può
che non stanno nè l'erba alta sono scemo
[Musica]
ciao ceti popolari
pokémon cazzo pedali zio
io stavo cercando i pokémon buona
giornata caro ciao una fortuna con le
palestre e proprio come in pochi non
regga si avvicinano gli allenatori
fantastico che è ricomparso un cazzo di
zu bud qui che è successo eccolo qui ma
non è vero ma non è vero non c'è sto
scherzando
resta fermo che cazzo o l'ho preso
dovrei sorpresissimo mai registrato nel
niente era destino che io prendessi un
sub up che mi fa veramente cagare posso
anche rinominare rinominiamo bene duro e
lui il mio zu bud ragazzino se becco
altri pokémon da che ci siamo ormai
capito da adatta da ratan tata anna ma
questo è vero ma che cazzo non ha
sbagliato
ciao fuori
i ragazzi dopo aver socializzato con
persone essere usciti all'aria aperta
direi che possiamo continuare con il
blog come sapete ragazzi ho già fatto
uscire due video di los angeles quindi
quando sono andato a los angeles per le
tre ho fatto due blog che hanno
riassunto la mia esperienza a los
angeles in questo blog voluto aggiungere
un pezzo che non ho messo negli altri
blog perché diciamo che io e mail siamo
andati a allo space center di los
angeles e ho praticamente bloccato
qualsiasi cosa quindi ragazzi siete
pronti per un altro viaggio perché sarà
bello pesante
l'esca lo re adesso ti faccio vedere per
la più altri so che non lo sai neanche
chi fanno e come si riproducono gli euro
inglobata da dietro come le tartarughe
dalle ore 9 eccolo ok pronti chi prende
più palline poi 2 contro lorenzo 321 via
romani mi toccano
prevedere le mani loro partito malissimo
ti arrendi ha vinto sachs hai usato i
chip non vale chimichiere in mano a
tantissime botte grosso è il pesce più
grosso che io abbia mai visto
moltissimo ma che non hai più pesci vita
mia mammina ho toccato il pesce
raga mi sa che si è rotto ragazzi mi
sono dimenticato dovevo parcheggiate
dove la macchina e l'ho trovata ancora
si chiama mega frullatore 2000 vendere a
merluzzo esatto perché frullato è meglio
frullatore 2000 ottima pressione per
triturare per bene le tue arance allora
abbiamo deciso di fare story vieni qua
dare un deciso di fare questa mega
challenge di scalare sco muro mai che si
spacca alla gamba titolo titolo fa vice
si spacca una gamba sarà una gara
all'ultimo sangue che riesce arrivare in
cima prima tra me e sasha lascia sei
pronto e sara che si farà solo una volta
due tentativi per arrivare in rai latte
premere il pulsante si sa se nei due fi
piano per capire che è arrivato così poi
nota che tu ce la farà a finirlo sasha
con calma con calma santo
lascia dovete fare lo scemo non puoi
scendere nel salire poi portati ok lo
restano troppo spedito è
oddio staff ed etico piano piano weissen
di lui non è cioè i ragazzi questo è
quello che è successo durante la
settimana hanno veramente alla roba di
los angeles e un po vecchia mai raffica
quindi volevo metterla nei prossimi
video che l'annuncio già iniziano a fare
tipo il test delle cose che ho comprato
los angeles visto che ne hanno tante tra
le quali la tavola wii già visto che
tutti quanti mi martellate il pene con
tavola di merda tranquilli meno ma sono
scordata purtroppo niente ragazzi e che
possa dio santo da favi domanda mica tra
i cuffie favi domanda io ormai all
alzheimer è confermato ragazzi caffè
vino vandali oggi e ci devo provare a
evocare con la tavola wii già visto che
allora voi non sapete come funziona sta
cazzo di tavola serve per evocare gli
spiriti lo farò sicuramente dalla
mezzanotte in poi
wow ditemi se avete un qualcuno da
evocare tipo il vostro prozio defunto e
prossimamente proverò a farlo spero
iddio che vostro zio sia una persona
calma perché potrebbero volare gli
schiaffi niente ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto e cosa e due
misure sono un commento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come noi
vive notizia né senza restituisca
precipitiamo proseguito e ragazzi